how do you stay humble when you know you
have better skillsets than others
you seem humble with all that you've
accomplished well this is just what like
in general just oh yeah be humble yeah
how do you stay humble when you know you
have better skillsets than others and
any saying that I seem humble with all
that I've accomplished which is which is
actually it's funny when I read that
like it's not I'm sure that for the dude
is asking this question he's thinking I
accomplished all the stuff and it's not
I don't feel that way like first of all
there's always somebody that's better
than you that's that I guarantee it
there's someone that's done more than
you there's someone that's had better
experience if someone's accomplished
more and and if you are truly the master
of some thing whatever one thing you're
a true master of there's gonna be people
that are a lot better at other things
than you so you might be the master of
one particular thing but are you you
have to respect the fact that people are
gonna be masters at other things or
better than you nothing I mean so if
you're super strong that's great let's
see you run a marathon if you're super
flexible awesome how much can you
deadlift if you're if you're smart that
that's great you're smart academically
let's check out your common sense and
see where all that's at you know so so
you're you you gonna be good at one
thing but you're gonna have failed in
other areas or have weaknesses in other
areas and so you just have to keep that
in check and I'll tell you like I why
I've been successful you know for one
thing been surrounded with great people
for other being lucky in certain
situations that I've been in certain
times and you you know going back to
jiu-jitsu a little bit it's a good
example because just because I can beat
someone in jiu-jitsu it it doesn't mean
that I'm a better person it does
it doesn't mean that I'm a better person
it what it means basically is that I
happen to get into this random fringe
sport before they did and I spent more
time on the math and they did that's
what it means it doesn't make me a
better person and I'll tell you what it
goes with you know if you're if you feel
like you're smarter than someone it's
probably because you've had the
opportunity to study a subject or you've
had a bunch of education on something
you've douve into some subjects so that
might make you seem smarter whereas if
they applied themselves in that
particular but guess what they were
applying themselves to something else so
yeah stay you got to stay humble with
that and also we know we talked about
this wouldn't you follow you know I am
smarter than this person well guess what
there's something there's still
something that they're better at than
you and what is it you might be smarter
than but guess what maybe what's a guy
we talked about earlier where I'm smart
as I could be guess what this person can
physically take me down and dominate me
and that's horrible or they're better at
whatever better athletically or some
people are really good craftsmen with
their hands I mean there's so many
different things so you can be skilled
at and if you start thinking that
yourself that you're that you're better
than other people you're gonna have
issues because in the long run do you
want to stay humble just stay alive
because life will Humphrey humble you
life is hard and if you're pushing hard
and you're driving hard and you're
trying to achieve a lot you're not
always gonna win I don't care who you
are you gonna get humbled it's gonna be
hard so many so many people that are
successful they've got some hard luck
stories along the way of things that
they had to push through and overcome in
order to get there they got humbled and
if you're winning every single time then
you're you're not the goals aren't high
enough so step those up so you know I
appreciate the the kind of comment but
man it's not hard to be humble when you
know you need to take like maybe someone
I didn't you know people always think Oh
oh he's a Navy SEAL or whatever you know
there's a lot of seals that are more
badass than me that done more
deployments that have gotten after it
more than me and I know that that that
that's awesome I mean good good for them
I you know they got after it good so I
don't feel like oh I did more than
everybody no there's no one like that
there's no one like that even even uh
you know Mikey Thornton who won't will
seal that one the Medal of Honor
awesome guy of you know just to just to
you know he's a he's a hero but if you
know he gets interviewed I've watched a
bunch of interviewed here and heard him
talk he's like you know he's like oh you
know you you you got the Medal of Honor
it's like it's not mine it's my guys you
know it's the guys I was with it
represents all so there's a guy like
who's gonna be if there's anyone in the
world that needs to that could not be
humble maybe it's Mikey Thornton but
guess what Mikey Thornton he's as humble
as they come cuz you know what he also
has been humbled by combat cuz he
realizes things that he tried to do that
he didn't get done there's lives he
tried to save that he couldn't save so
you're gonna there's no doubt if you're
living the right life you're gonna be
humbled by it and there's always always
always gonna be somebody that's better
than you that somebody you so just stay
humble and by the way what does being
cocky gets you anyways what does that
turn you into what we've talked about
somewhat is what does overconfidence get
you you start cutting corners you start
slack I mean it's just ridiculous so you
got to stay humble you got to stay
hungry if you if you want to stay in the
game and believe me you want to stay in
the game you want to stay in the game do
you think that like and I I can't I mean
I don't know if maybe this is where this
even the question is coming from but if
you know when you're insecure and you
like you're just like everything is a
competition like just in life it's it's
like it goes beyond just what you're
into it's just like it sounds better
than me so it makes me mad it makes you
uneasy or whatever it's like this
insecurity kind of thing
so when you do it so if you look at
everything is just this big life
compared like I got a beat that guy
gotta be better than them so when you
are better than them it's like you're
still looking at it as this competition
like yeah you know like you're not on my
level so you don't deserve to be treated
it's kind of like it maybe this is a
good analogy maybe not but like in
jiu-jitsu where if you roll with a white
belt you don't go hard you don't get
satisfaction or whatever so in the Jiu
Jitsu competition arena you're not
giving them the respect you're not going
all-out like you would you know you're
not respecting his own farm bar you know
if you are you're smashing no
satisfaction you know whatever it's in
that specific competition setting but if
you're just an insecure person where you
think that all life is like just one big
competition no you got to smash that
person yeah and if you're not worthy of
my smashing it's like I don't even treat
you like you should be on the mats with
me on a single but me I mean do you
think that maybe that's where some of
that comes from like if you're having
trouble like being humble it's kind of
like I'm better than you in life yes
probably just had just driven from
insecurity but there's also a there's a
dichotomy there too because man I like
to win
like I like no doubt about it I like to
win and in the dichotomy of it is is
that I also don't literally don't care
like if I get beat I'm like okay well I
what can I do to get better or what it's
not I don't feel this despair because I
lost losing actually kind of motivates
me more yeah as opposed to getting angry
and the worst thing that happens is
people decide they're not going to
compete right they're not gonna compete
in the game of life because they didn't
win or they don't feel like they can win
so they go ah you know what I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna back off I'm just
not gonna participate in the game but
get in the game get in the game theme so
maybe it comes from not understanding
what that means when you win and stuff I
guess I guess no like literally like
like the fight like back to the fighting
situation where the about you know being
a secure part of
balancing rel psyche if you know that
you've achieved these skills have these
skills to win people you know who don't
have your skill set you don't want to
fight them so you're just like whatever
but let's say like you have a better
skill set yet you're still blowing your
horn about your skill set you know
you're not humble about it it's like he
comes from maybe on an awesome yes
there's no doubt there could be some
insecurity that charges that makes
people super competitive
beyond healthy right just like in like
I'm just in life you know no matter what
which again there's people that are that
way myself included and but again that I
kata me is no no I I know I am okay I
Know Who I am
remember echelon front remember the logo
yeah right
and I'm gonna post this on Twitter to
jockle made the original echelon front
logo yeah yeah and you're like a you
know this is the logo something like
this and then basically but you didn't
care that it was junk no no but I all I
wanted to do is get you the I do you
weren't competing with me but you drew
and I drew but like it like as someone
who's competing in everything in life
like if you draw something and I draw
something you're like I wanna make my
better no no nobody but well I see I
wanted to win with the idea not with the
skill the LIA idea or I wanted to win
the war not the short-term battles like
who can draw this thing better that the
war was who comes up with a strategic
victory which the icon and the symbol
for echelon front is the one that I drew
I liked it so yes I didn't care that it
looked like junk because I'm not I was
just did it with uhyou post-sex is
pretty funny I did on PowerPoint with
like a like a crayon looks like a crayon
because I I didn't want to take much
time with I know I knew that that thing
would take you 15 minutes to make on
your what is it a I ill illustrator that
might have been don't be mad at me
that's probably the first logo I've ever
actually made
maybe they're very successful yah-hoo
thanks for trusting me